good morning believe nation today's
message is do it because you feel it
over to you Ralph Lauren I wake up every
mood nespresso TV go everything I've
always done it's been for my own emotion
and we've never done for a brand or a
label it's it's it's because I feel it
and we give it a title event it it's
what it takes it away from me I think
it's a really important message because
I encourage entrepreneurs always always
make the big decisions with your heart
and the small ones with the head and too
often I think we make these lists of
pros and cons and why should we go for
this opportunity or not and quite often
the one that makes the most logical
sense the one that everybody tells you
to do the one that looks the best on
paper the one that when you line up all
your pros and cons and compare one
against the other quite often that
decision is the wrong one for you
because your head can only understand
the world that currently exists where
your heart can create a new world that
hasn't existed yet Richard Branson is
famous are saying that he doesn't
involve accountants in any of his deals
until he's already closed it because in
his view at least accountants are people
who only look at a world that currently
exists and aren't the dreamers where you
have to be a dream right if you want to
go and create an ideal life for yourself
it doesn't yet exist it doesn't fit into
any box you have to create that box and
so you want to do the things that make
you come alive you want to do the things
that get you excited where you can't
sleep where you're sitting by your
bedside writing notes and still working
and working on these ideas you want to
do things that make you come alive when
you wake up in the morning and you want
to get going and get that project done
you know there are some things that
waking up at five in the morning sounds
like oh god wake up if I'm anymore and I
got this meaningful you will go to do
those projects but then term there are
some other days when maybe you're
booking a flight some more maybe you're
working as some really exciting project
and waking up at five in the morning
there's no problem and so you want to
concentrate on finding
opportunities that make you come alive
instead of living like The Walking Dead
instead of just living the 925 lifestyle
and living for the the weekends and the
evenings where hopefully get to have a
little bit of fun because that's that's
most people most people don't enjoy
their lives you want to do things
because you feel it you want to do
things that make you come alive i look
at my youtube channel last night i was
up till midnight reviewing the videos
I've got five people six people on my
YouTube team now I still review every
single second of video before goes out
now that doesn't mean I I don't make
mistakes and some mistakes slip through
the cracks but I am still involved in
every aspect of it because I love it you
know I've been trying to give up pieces
but but I love it so much I care so much
I find so much value in the videos and I
want it to have a positive impact on
your lives right I don't want to just
give it away to somebody it has to be
meaningful and I get so much value from
it still that's why I'm up till midnight
still working on these projects and
thankfully you have a wife who's very
supportive and very understanding and as
part of the team and it's helping me
answer your questions so I want you to
find something that you feel that
passionately about as well if you're
waking up and you're going to your
office and you're sitting in front of
your laptop and you just feel like
you're grinding it out instead of
actually doing something that makes you
come alive you can only do that for so
long before you need to tell yourself I
need to change something I need to find
something new for myself and that's not
to say that every day is amazing and
every day is roses and peaches and every
day you're making tons of money but if
that happens for too many days in a row
if you look at yourself in mirror for
too many days and you're not happy then
change something and how you know that
you're on the right track to the new
thing is because it feels right so the
question that a few guys today is what
do you do that makes you come alive and
feels right leave in the comments below
I'm going to join the discussion thank
you so much for watching have an amazing
day continue to believe and they'll see
you again tomorrow morning for another
shot events press 0
this prey so give me go